HELLO, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
I AM BANCHEZ IFO
A  ENTCO.N UNDERWER
ANIOH PACIFI AT THIS
TE IMAGES
SHOWING A MASSIVASD
K WAVES.
E ER
ISLAATION OF
THE LARGEST , SENDING
WAVENGO THCA
INUNDATINGHE
ALNS US LI
FROM THE CNN WEATHF , WHAT
IS THERE A CHANCE THIS COME A T?
ON'T THINK BECOM
LOOKED AT
OTHES AND HAWAIIAME.WE HAVE AN .
HE'ST INATI EA
SOOUT 14 MILLION PEO ARE EXPECTW
I FROTH 7:30 AN
10 I VIE
WIDE SOHEN YOOUT HOW MANY STAT
IT RANS , KA TO
9:05:00 A.M.
WE'LL O 50. IN ERE
D SAN FRANCIOSE ARE IN TIMESHAWI
UP, BUE MEE IPLEDS.
MOST OF THEM RANGE BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA, INEG.T IT.T COAST OS
ONE FO HH
BUS ENOUGH.
IF YRE STANDIN
SHEL TO WASH OFF
IT IS. K YOU DOWN. SURFING, DON
ON THREE THEN SHG
SHE SHORELIN IS E VIDEO WE HAVEE
E IMAGERY.
U THON ITSELF.
ARND E, YOU CAN SEE
VES THAT WERE
CRTEOM ERUPTIO
ITSELFHERE IMAGE.
NOTICE ON THE OUTEDEA LO
NGTHICULAR SATELLITE.
N,YOA SLOWER
OU
DOINGS OMED 1
DECEMBER, AL TIME,E.AD SNIMI
WAVES   S THE FARTHERTO PACIF W
CALIFORN, WASHINGTON,
EVEN ALASKA, WE ONLYING EEFOTHO.
VE TEAT ISTILL A GOOD IDEA FOR
PELE CAREFUL I, THANO
WE'LL BE CHECKING INU
R THISHE MAJOR
UN.FHE
THANU THN.  TO BRIN
DR SCIENCE JOURNALIST,
EC EXPER
SUVIEARS AGOSTUIM THERSEE THTIV.
YOE RATHER J D
SATELLIT
SOMETIMES
ERONH WATER IN
F THUPTION, KIND THE ATMOSPHOU
DO ANAN MADE E INTHAT SN E THA
SENG LGELOSION
S ONGOIN
N DECEMBER.THIN UNSUR
HAPPENED HERE, BUTI U O DILA AY.
OF ANDHEA WA WAY.
VIT  ERUPTION, RTIALLY UNDERWATM
IE IT IE  MOMENT,H PEOPLE
GHH THEM. WY O RE
WATCH THISIDEO
GETTING INUNDATEANPITAL OF TONGA
YOU MENTION THAT THIRTHEF FIWHE
THEOFIR IT ARITVOCTED HE SHAPE
OF THE VOLCANOS AROUND TCIFIC.
GOINR,T SETSS.E ONE
THAR W VOLCANICALLACTIVITY.
WHEN THEEEN INWA
NE WY MORE
ERUPTIONE MOMENTS A USEN
PARTICULARLY WITH QU.ESSOR FROMS
D
HSOULDOT T HE.W ASSENTUPTION EPA
THATTLTO ME.
E F THINTHAT IS HARD PIN DOWS.
I KNIE FAMILIA
CARY
LANDS.
THATEGERAL MONTHS ITG TO
GO ON FOWE MONTHS. THE HARDES
NGW LONG WILL ANRUPTIO
ERTIL ST LESS,
S
CAN'T SEE HOW MUCH MAGMALIED FRS
USLL
TO
SCIEISTS GENAS
ERUPTIONS, THESE THINGS CAN